sí
de acuerdo sumerja monos en el uso de
partículas para simular agua
antes de hablar acerca de cómo se mueven
grandes cantidades de partículas
comencemos examinando cómo se mueve una
partícula si dejó caer una partícula o
una pelota de ping pong esta acelera
hacia el suelo y todo este tipo de
movimiento ya lo vimos en el tema de
animación
presta atención a qué rebota de regreso
pero no tan alto como al comienzo pierde
un poco de energía durante el rebote y
finalmente cuando pierde toda su energía
se detiene
ahora veamos nuestro simulador de
pelotas de ping pong donde damos forma a
cada pelota mediante el uso de una
partícula virtual la partícula virtual
acelera hacia abajo hasta que se topa
con un obstáculo y entonces rebota de
regreso con un poco menos de energía con
este simulador podemos controlar el
tamaño de la partícula mediante el uso
de este deslizador
también podemos controlar la fuerza de
la gravedad mediante el uso de este
deslizador un valor gravitacional
pequeño similar al de la gravedad que se
encuentra en la luna provoca que la
partícula caiga más lentamente
un valor gravitacional mayor como la
gravedad que tenemos en nuestro planeta
provoca que la partícula siga una
velocidad más común
y un valor gravitacional muy grande como
el de júpiter hace que la partícula
caiga muy rápido
también podemos controlar cuánta energía
pierde la partícula durante un rebote
mediante el control de elasticidad esto
describe la fracción de energía que se
conserva
cuando la partícula rebota
la elasticidad es un número entre 0 y 1
un valor de 1 significa que la partícula
no pierde energía rebotara por siempre a
esto se le llama condiciona totalmente
elástica y es algo que no sucede en la
vida real un valor de 0 significa que la
partícula pierde toda su energía y en
este caso se queda en el piso los
valores intermedios dan a la partícula
un movimiento más realista
la elasticidad también se utiliza para
controlar la pérdida de energía cuando
las partículas colisionan entre sí si
ajustamos la elasticidad en cero
entonces las partículas perderán toda la
energía cuando colisionan como aquí
igual que un montón de canicas
conforme aumentamos la elasticidad
obtenemos algo más parecido a las
pelotas de goma
y por supuesto también puedes cambiar el
tamaño de las partículas
hagamos una pausa aquí para que puedas
usar el siguiente ejercicio y adquirir
un poco de práctica con el
comportamiento de las partículas que se
puede obtener al cambiar su tamaño la
gravedad y la elasticidad